like an exclusive top 975 bootleg keV
live in studio right now J Cole what's
up right here yeah yeah how you feeling
man I'm doing good man it's been a
minute man how's uh how's the Drake tour
going it's good man yet the early stages
is fun yes where's a lot of rappers lot
of rappers I think we scared Live Nation
movie hey for real I know you and Drake
you guys share a lot of the same fans is
it kind of cool to go on tour and see I
mean that's a big tour you know it's a
big audience singing singing some you
know your album you don't mean that has
been anticipated for so long finally
came out in September absolutely
what's that like man seeing people
really vibe to the hard work it's this
incredible feeling you know to be you
know when you do a singles it's a rap
you know saying like but but to be able
to do a few album cuz I only got so much
time on stage but to be able to do a few
other album joints and and see people
crowded no word for word I do dilator
dream and they know it you know and then
a real cool thing is like I don't know
how cool it is for them but you know
ticket prices kind of determine where
you sitting right so it's like you got
these people in front of a die-hard
Drake friends and they paid Lots prices
I just like happy level right saying
even some of them like a lot of them
know like word for but the real crazy
thing is like if I squint my eyes and I
look way in the back you know can we
don't like amphitheaters you have a way
in the back is like a punch to like die
off and you see the cold world shows
like so my friends it's kind of like hey
there lady paid $100 like they couldn't
go to the 250 or whatever right in the
front but they are the way they're in
the back so they are rocking with you um
the first album and I got to give you
congratulations you got nominated for
the Grammy
yes the album in gold where I had the
illest bone to pick with with MTV man
because you did not make the freshmen
this but the hottest that was right
right inexcusable
and I'm like this dude's got a gold
album I would gladly go down Grammy
nominee how did you I mean I know you
you don't probably let that kind of
stuff get to you but it's got to kind of
be like come on son like word yeah it
was it just let me know like what that
whole thing was you know I'm saying it's
a couple people in that pan without
respect so it's no disrespect to them
but just let me know what that thing is
you know I'm saying it like and I had me
questioning like man what is this coach
we live in where like a few a few people
were like we talked reckless on Twitter
and gather followers you know sanneh are
looking for attention or looking for
some kind of spot or work within the
industry like have disappeared that
matters you know I'm saying that like it
goes to so many people cuz you got kids
in Wisconsin that see that and they
don't really know the truth they're like
oh man yeah so they don't see my name
when they just think you know they don't
really know so like you know that's an
important job you have you got to take
that a little more serious there was
like people on the list
that I was like you know I wasn't mad
Meek Mill like I I know why they I know
why I understand why they justify
putting him on the list for Mike he
don't have an album out whiz's bit hot
but I'm like cold the last 12 months man
is far away there's nobody that wouldn't
want to send them this like definitely
not that person that looks like oh man
this dude not like that everyone was
definitely doing it yeah man so uh let's
talk about what's next man the second
album bro no you probably actually I
know for a fact you've been working on
it because Mike told me y'all were
working a little bit uh when can we
expect I don't know I don't know to date
but I mean I'm so deep in like I got so
much music right now I came in with
music right from like first album
process and then once I started I was
like I'm not doing I'm not gonna rely on
those old songs yeah like I'm not gonna
get none of those old songs I'm making
it to his album I came in with that
mentality and I started when I was in
Europe I started working on tour over
there making a little bit it's like the
music that was coming out so incredibly
so since then I just have a stockpile of
music a lot of unfinished you know a lot
of great ideas like
no and I'm just I'm just making music I
think by the end of this Drake tour I'll
start picking songs and finalizing that
happen but man I can't you know I got
too many songs for an album like that's
that's the tough part in this day and
age like you only get 14 songs on that
album one man it starts costing you
money to put somewhere I'm like somebody
this is more like what can people how
much can people digest it once you know
you say so sometimes you know less is
more
so you know I got one thing about the
first album that you know I'm a big fan
of year so you know I got all the
mixtapes there's so much material on the
first album that I had heard absolutely
I was like I was like man hard even hurt
some of that was due to like leaking
some of that was like I put lights
please on them and the singles you
contribute the leaks and the singles
like I just had to bite that bullet on
the first album yeah yeah I honestly if
you but the real thing is if mother in a
perfect world if things would happen to
have like young naive Jayco could have
had it then it took a lot of those songs
off Friday Night Lights and they'd have
been on the album and makes a few of the
songs off the album and that would have
been the original first album there
would've been no fighting they're like
sort of just been you know one of those
albums but I had to bite the bullet
it kind of just you know and just you
know just tuck it out for the first one
and like write songs they had to get
hurt no I know I hear yeah that was I
was like because I remember you tweeted
the track listing were like live and I
was like wait a minute it's all good
though man you're you know you you've
you've built your fanbase up you know
you're you're one of the the key kind of
figures that you know kind of use the
internet to really um you know taking
advantage of the Internet it's a pop are
you are you interested in putting out
another mixtape is that even man that's
that I would like to pass it I'm not
above it or nothing cuz that's what made
me write and I do have a stockpile of
music that I would love for the people
here I just think it's got to be a
better way and I'm just trying to come
up with a more interesting way to do
this right you know what I'm saying to a
put some value back on the music
let's put value on our music again and
I'm saying like even if it's a 50 cent
even if it's five dollars for a mixtape
like this but that's why I really like
how Top Dawg did it everything you gotta
buy it everything every so so when
Kendrick
blows you can go back and buy his
mixtapes no say no indeed and because
King Carter's makes a job so I really
respect how they did it they put value
on their thing so even if you only sell
ten thousand five thousand right and you
sold them and when you blow people were
going back to buy cattle nobody can go
by the Walmart right now on Friday Night
Lights which is a crime
that's a car it's funny you say that I
was gonna ask you a the last couple
songs that you you've been releasing the
one that I really love is to grow up
fast joint it's almost like whenever
like a new Jake whole song comes out
like cuz lately
I mean since the album came out like as
far as new material though it's been
like three records I was the record you
came out with I think only they dreaded
my primer what was that what was that
when I was returning to Simba
appreciate it yeah so yeah two records
so to since down which was Brewer
Affairs and visitors at home what uh
what kind of inspired like when you
release songs like that just out of
nowhere it just kind of just to kind of
keep your name out there that's it and
that's what I'm not I'm not gonna lie
almost got I almost right around the
time of grew up fast
yeah like as the artist you get to this
place where it's like that's why I'm not
on Twitter no more I'm not doing it and
I'm not worried and I'm not going to it
um and the same thing about like
dropping music it's like as an artist
I'm sitting back and watching all these
other artists who I respect I want to
some of them are big artists right on
Twitter like fighting for attention like
every tweet is like I'm looking forward
to me retweet me I'm you know I'm saying
and I saw that and then the same thing
about songs like the chopper songs like
all comes from this place of fear like I
don't want to lie to forget about me
it really comes from that place like oh
man we're not hot right now but really
if your body of work speaks for you so
it's doing work even when you're not
knowing it but because you're not only
when you talk about you on Twitter
you're not the trending topic or your
mixtape may turn in is like you feel a
certain way so I'm saying that to say
that when I job grew up fast
I almost got trapped in this place where
I was gonna drop a song every like and
then I realized like nah I'm not that
type of like I don't need to go fight
for attention like when it's my time I'm
gonna load up all my clips on it's time
I'm gonna empty them out and then start
working in the next project but I'm not
gonna
in the meantime worry about like my name
not being talked about like nah I'm not
gonna play that game hey the way you
record man um you and uh you know Mike's
like one of my really really close close
homies he was supposed to call and ask
you a question but he's like man you
gotta talk to him about how he records
his music we do it the same yeah because
like he like when I first saw Mike in
the studio trip me out he got his own
mic he just does everything on his Mac
like million-dollars studio equipment
all around him knives right there yeah
has is that kind of did you kind of kind
of because I know he did that way cuz
you know he was he was recording music
in his dorms and I know you've been
doing music since she was an image was
that kind of how you adopted that way I
got it for I did get it from Mike Posner
because I do everything on my own and
I've been recording myself for a while
but once I started going to a real
studio I got an engineer so I started
going in to move really before that I
was in my room I didn't have it like him
right for people that don't know what
mike posner does is he sets a mic right
in front of his face he sits down and he
and he he does the beat and he sings his
vocals and you know on his lap all on
his laptop
so what I was doing was I do the beat
but then I'll bring my beat to the
studio and then go in the booth and had
my internet record me and when one side
and I see used to see videos of Calle
doing that - he had to migrate from his
face and sit down and record itself but
um once my composer told me how he did
it when somebody came to the studio is
that right - Mike I was like man I need
to do that I didn't know I could record
right onto my laptop once I got like the
interface you know sound I just adopted
that style so now what I do is I do the
same thing I sit down you know I don't
to move no more I'll just do it I just
said that it is a video Watch the Throne
tour doc you're not to a documentary one
of the episodes and I'm making the album
you'll see Jana sitting down he's doing
this a I don't know if he doesn't do it
all the time okay I think for that time
it was out in Australia I think that's
right how you a was going it and you see
it's crazy CJ like sitting down rapping
his raps chillin were like trying to
perfect his round so yeah I definitely
got that from my posing on there that's
a good look man well a we can't wait for
the second album yeah drop some you know
I mean maybe a song a month the home so
yeah maybe the longer they wait you
better pay off yeah you know you can
when it actually starts is gonna be a
beautiful thing real quick before you go
man who I mean youyou got Missy Elliott
on the new album or on the only on the
first album it's not really new anymore
well which was a crazy feature you know
I haven't heard Missy on a rap song in a
minute yes you actually are no way right
now all the way back so yeah the new
album man who who was you know two or
three artists that kind of on your your
wish list that aren't you know jay-z or
Andre 3000 or anybody that you to say
yeah yeah I promise you I don't even
think about these things I just start
working with Kendrick the other day we
got in finally again that mixtape that
show oh man it's like folklore
album and Kendrick J Cole man album
album tape so y'all are officially
working on that yeah we were okay cuz
yeah oh my man this is this is gonna be
one of these mad I don't think it is you
know why we never gonna come out he got
back in those the first time we got back
in in a while we actually got another
night actually worked like bouncing
ideas you know what I'm saying which is
great in the vibe is so good that is
like man y'all do we got like maybe a
four four or five together you know I'm
saying the very worst tracks where
that's what it is man way much love
tonight it's going down make sure you go
see the home and let's get a new record
right now nobody's perfect once you
introduce that yes sir y'all ready No
it's Jay Cole Cole we're rocking with my
man bootleg keV you right here on hot
now 75 baby this is Jay Cole feature
Missy Elliott nobody's perfect